what's the worst thing that can happen
if brexit does actually become a reality
how do you feel about your man as useful
as tits on a nun
you hear people that say there's one
thing I don't know I don't do politics I
don't even want to follow it I don't
want to do anything I'm sorry if you're
an entrepreneur you paying taxes you
better pay attention to politics because
one regulation could affect your
business that's the top of my head and
that's my brain if Islam is so fantastic
why do muslims always come to christian
countries for refuge so one of the
things i want to do with the vitamin
audience is kind of get us educated on
what's happening around the world i know
a lot of times it's a lot of us
interviews we do i decided to go to
london we are in london right now and
meet with somebody who i think every
time she tweets something half of UK
goes crazy on what she said she's got a
lot of different nicknames a lot of
things people call her Katie Hopkins
we're gonna talk about a people who
don't like exercise too much we're gonna
talk a little politics we're gonna talk
a little bit about moms maybe a little
bit of feminism a little bit of taxes
brexit a little bit of all that stuff
today with Katie Hagen okay thank you so
much
oh we're making a time I really enjoyed
the lot that we had earlier did I
introduced you to them you are mate
would not man but it's not coffee right
or was it he said no no you don't drink
coffee so we've had to slightly
backpedal on that that it definitely
wasn't a coffee that I gave you and and
what was interesting is Katie said you
don't have a tendency of losing things
you know I just have a tendency of
leaving things behind I said I'm so
embarrassed to say I just lost my wallet
and she says no so she was kind enough
we called the driver she's talking to
the driver and the people they're just
whole different experience but we grant
you one here we found my thing is when I
have somebody who you know an instant
friend I have to I will fight like a
little lioness to to solve that problem
that was amazing seeing you in action
bug that's the stuff that people don't
see behind a camera not how somebody is
that was just fascinating you know so
I'll fix it yes so why don't we get into
it you look at people and I study
personalities I'm curious I'm so curious
about how people are and what made them
the way they are you're somebody that so
you seem very comfortable in your own
skin and the opinions that you say
things that rattles a lot of people out
there before going into some of your
opinions this is a simple question for
you if you and I were in high school
together
you're sixteen seventeen I'm sixteen
seventeen who's Katie Hopkins
at high school sixteen seventeen Katie
Hopkins is never talk about yourself in
the third person fact is finding school
pretty easy so it's not hard to get
straight A's as it was then before you
had a stars I'm in the netball team I've
done my grade eight violin my grade
eight piano mm-hmm stuffs not hard for
me in terms of doing getting the grades
I'm supposed to get and getting the
marks I'm supposed to get and having
certificates for my parents to put on
the wall and I'm walking to and from
school every day I have a normal family
house with a mom and dad that are still
together now amazingly all these years
later have always been together
mum's a housewife and my father worked
on the electrical pylons like the
overhead cable so super normal girl and
my high school was run by nuns which is
the one thing so I went to a Catholic
yeah I know so for all of my hideous
reputation in many different regards I
went I was brought up by nun so my I
hold the nuns largely responsible for my
poor behavior everything limit on the
nuns
oh it's and I never knew like who
decided that nuns could teach like
someone just where are a nun she must be
a teacher like what who does that no one
ever decided that for monks particularly
never had boys schools run by monks but
anyway yes I went to a convent girl
school and I was never allowed to be the
Virgin Mary for any number of reasons
but at the Christmas play you could only
be Virgin Mary if you were a Catholic
and I had my sign left hand and I used
to assist a bead form three I still
remember her and she's to tie my left
hand up behind my back because good
people wrote with their right hand
because good people yeah I'm only 42 as
well I'm telling stories like I'm six
yeah hardcore you'll remember that no
matter vividly yeah I can remember that
being having to stay in and practice
writing with a hand I don't write with I
grew up thinking left-handed people were
special people like they have an edge
like it's a chip like hey I'm different
then that makes me yes I have a daughter
that's just like me she's left-handed -
no I definitely identify with
left-handed people but maybe that's why
the nuns wanted to you know be
interesting so in your family if I'm
having dinner at your house mom dad
electrical engineer stay home mom would
there debate did you talk politics did
you know exports nothing so one thing at
five to five
you'd be sat down and I'd be sat down my
sister my mom and then my dad would sit
down at five o'clock dinner always no
change
five o'clock dinner conversation I don't
even remember us talking about stuff we
must have talked about school and normal
things no it wasn't the kind of crazy
that would sit there so did you hear
what he said what do you think about
this political now that's gone not at
all no at all and certainly with my kids
now I know that we can talk about all
sorts of things and I'll ask them what
did you see about you know the volcano
or did you hear about that and I'll
check that they have dialed into stuff I
think they should know but I don't
remember that about my childhood I do
remember and not being able to leave my
plate until it was finished 100% was a
mom dad or bonnet there was the
discipline both of them but particularly
we were scared of my dad in terms of you
know he was the figure of the family
that you were you didn't mess with and I
don't I don't regret that or want to
change that that was how it was we knew
where we stood steak and kidney pie
that's when I remember the bits of
kidney sitting looking at them wondering
how to get out of that so very normal
very standard very it's why quite like
order discipline people doing what makes
sense in order to get an end result
because with a lot of my growing up do
enough of the work you'll get an a no
problem
play the violin hard enough you'll get a
distinction at grade eight no problem
like I understand what you have to do
yes systems processes rules and you were
comfortable with that I get them you
know my dad said we have to be kids six
five and at will my dad says kids neat
systems because it's a level of
predictability that gives them trust and
peace so it's amazing how you're saying
it with these toys I almost wonder
whether my super normal
supernormal upbringing you know a mom
and dad really my dad you know worked a
lot of hours to be able to get me and my
sister to the school that I slightly
took the mickey out of but you know
maybe that super normal upbringing is
what gives you enough space in your head
in your mind to then go on and kind of
burst out what are they ship come on
what did it ship come because almost
everybody I see that's chippy or a
little bit confrontational comfortably
confrontational kind of like yourself
there is an event there is something
happened that you know triggered
something I don't know what it was I
mean I know you for yourself when you
were coming up you wanted to go to
Oxford something's happened there and
then you want to do military you want
military there was some things
health-wise at the end yes
when did your chip meanest what event
was there an event that you remember or
no yeah I think my chief penis is
because at 17 I was diagnosed with
epilepsy or suspected epilepsy and that
was the start of a 20 year epilepsy a
lifetime with epilepsy until recently
and those fits got more and more
significant so it's almost always been
all of my life actually hiding an
illness that I didn't want anyone to
know about overcoming the things that
may have kept me back because of that
epilepsy and then determined to be
better than that and be anybody else and
that's definitely where my penis is
that's why I had to leave after I passed
out of Sandhurst because they found out
I had epilepsy and it's what I've been
pretending I didn't have all of my life
whilst going on and being on The
Apprentice or being this personal
standing up and speaking to 2,000 people
it's always been about you don't know
I'm epileptic you don't know I
dislocated both my arms in the night
with a fit and look I'm this is me and
so running and all of that stuff all the
fitness stuff was always about being
knowing that actually secretly I was
probably weaker than a lot of people but
needing to have a front that was
ultimately strong Wow and that's that's
that's so interesting I think you said
something where every 10 days your arms
your elbows would and that lasted for
like what two years a couple years I
lasted he was in that back end of my so
I don't have fit how squeamish are you
know okay so this is not too weird I'm
not about to put your hand summer
I saw the fear in your eyes like there's
this ad go so that's the top of my head
and that's my brain so I'm like man with
no shell that's the surgery the surgery
that cured me of the epilepsy so I no
longer have my brain that's your brain I
portrayed yes so they go in with a
circular saw there was a team of 12 took
like 18 hours and they saw the top of
your head off and then they open up your
skull they go in I don't know what this
is I presume it's some sort of shovel
they go in and like a miner in a in a
tunnel and they got out this sort of
tumour thing that was causing where
Pepsi got rid of it then they do put
that flap back in but mine went really
manky which is a medical term for
meningitis and so they went back in and
threw it away so that's just my brain I
just dropped about with so what did he
do I have my protector to safety or
whatever I can get a titanium one
there's one in the printer already a
titanium roof top what was a risk was it
was it to the point where you were so
sick and tired of experience 420 or like
I'm either gonna do it and may cost me
my life but I can't live like that would
you at that point yes so I had to two
years was the span they said that a fit
would get me within a two-year time
frame and so every morning's I used to
be on the road on the road on the road
determined I would text my mum I'm here
and texts my husband I'm here and it's
funny I still go to go to my phone now
and go I'm here but then I'm like I
don't need to tell you all over here
they know I'm here because that was just
about letting people know I got through
the night so I was just saying I'm here
in the morning because my mum would need
to check and then yeah my Fitz used to
dislocate both my arms out of their
sockets but I've had them resewn on now
so I'm like terminator Hopkins and
you're good now I mean this is
yeah like though this is part of the
other reason for this phase is now I'm
like I'm of epic proportions in my head
because I've got a whole new life what's
changed what have you noticed after the
procedure changed that maybe you didn't
have before I can go to sleep and not
fear I wake up and don't have to test
people that I'm alive I don't have to
wonder if I have arms in the morning or
not I don't bite my tongue off anymore
but that's why
small things like being called names
they have a on a scale of perspective
I've been gifted perspective it doesn't
bother you life has some enormity to it
and brain surgery is fairly enormous so
it was left hold on
left left arm the deficit so you could
lose your left arm left leg sight or
speech were my risks so I got all of
that back so my eyes that's why I feel
like I have a purpose oh my gosh of
course especially if your gift is
speaking and communicating a message
that revenue in your and your mind it's
like taking a person who's a writer and
you take their arms out how am I gonna
express myself it's a very powerful
thing my good friend Robert Greene
author he just finished his book laws of
human nature and he had a big stroke
right after finishing the book and his
entire the left side when you see the
interview this is how he moves his arm
this is how he would look like that and
we were talking I said he's he sincerely
seemed concerned because it's Patrick
the way I've been expressing myself last
30 years is through writing yes and he's
you know and you can see the struggle of
somebody that's got so much to offer but
they're going through this oh I yes I
can see how that probably had an effect
now well that's gone glad thank you for
sharing that I don't speak about it very
much because a its long and convoluted
and B it's a side of me that I always
kept hidden so it doesn't really come
into play but I think it's a secret that
I kept for so long and now I'm better
maybe I'm able to talk about it because
I don't feel strange anymore
so sometimes for example like I had to
make a 180 of my life right I was a kid
that was coming up and I was seen as
this guy who was a party guy you go
party with me you gonna have a great
time and we're gonna go do all this
stuff and then one day I switched and so
all my circle everybody who knew me was
like wait a minute what happened we
don't like this new guy why are you so
serious why are you so determined to go
out there when I had a chip myself as
one an experience that took place do you
think the world expected Katie to be
Katie and is there anything about Katie
that you want to change now or you're
comfortable with the lady that was the
fornicator that is there Katie 3.0 4.0 I
think this is an evolution now and so I
don't think I've done a 180 but I think
I've allowed this other me this this
epileptic me the me that worried
about not being around for my kids the
me that was in the casualty or a A&E or
ER to your guys at 3:00 in the morning
having her shoulders put back in you
know that I've allowed her to catch up
or maybe I've allowed big strong Katie
to come back and those two people be
like identifying the same person I've
allowed those two people to be the same
hence I'm able to speak about this
openly I wouldn't ever bore someone with
this it did that just for reassurance if
anyone's ever thinking of inviting me to
dinner it's not a story I'd sell but
I've allowed those two people now to
join up and I think it's a much more
honest to me and it's also of me that
other people they get this part of me I
wrote about in my book and and people
then went on and bought the book for
like their friends who maybe were
undergoing chemo or a really horrible
divorce or had just lost their job and
we're feeling rubbish about themselves
and it became a kind of book for people
that saw actually we all have a bit of a
rubbish time and we can come on after
that so it became like a nice thing
unfortunately most of us are not
comfortable bringing it out and talking
about it because we have to have that
facade and we cover ourselves up because
in case we show a certain level of
weakness because you know the whole
saying you can never show weakness never
show hurt never show this and I agree
with that still I do as well yeah 100%
do I do but I think from my perspective
is I like a person's human side when I
see it and I say wow I respect your
opinions but I now connect with you on
the human side I don't connect with you
and let you see whatever yeah whatever
opinion on what it would like but I
connect with you I'm there so at least
we have something in common and I think
that's true for a lot of people that
know a bit about me or know me or have
met me or meet me in the street and they
can feel I thought I hated you but
actually or they'll come and listen to a
talk and I get people at the start right
hands up who thinks I'm a cow you know
and the whole room will be like or
people will start to be bravely I think
you're a cow and then by the end people
will come up and say it's really
annoying now I came here and I really
wanted to hate I can't hate you as much
as I thought I did so there's that but
but I still say you know though that our
lives are such that the evolution of a
you know a certain age you can be this
person I've been able to reconcile
epileptic me and big bold annoying me
and that's the same now but but for
those early years the 20s to 30s do I
regret being that bolshie nothing's
gonna stop me epilepsy won't beat me
person no not at all I think they were
that was intrinsic to me I would what I
wanted to feel sorry for myself and take
disability benefits and tell employers
I've got epilepsy so they didn't hire me
not a chance
well respect for you to stay true to
your core principles which is solid so
why don't we go into that and talks
about some of those principles it's a
wide range right and I think why don't
we just start off with something basic
right now we'll talk about different
topics and you give me your thoughts or
banter a little bit and we'll go to the
next topic yeah and the next topic let's
start off with something where you know
my goal a lot of times with
entrepreneurs there's a lot of you hear
people that say there's one thing I
don't do I don't do politics I don't
even want to follow it I don't want to
do anything I'm sorry if you're an
entrepreneur you paying taxes you better
pay attention to politics because one
regulation could affect your business I
can't tell you how many CEOs call me and
they tell me well you know this one
regulation changed the game for me and
our revenue has dropped 40 percent well
you should pay attention to some of the
stuff that's going on and rather than
just saying well I'm not gonna do
anything with this so let's talk brexit
and let's talk you this is an event that
took place a couple years ago and I
think there's like seven other countries
right now that are trying to separate
themselves from the EU somebody watches
this on a YouTube they watch us other
places they hear EU brexit why our
countries part of EU what is the benefit
of being part of you and Ellis talk
about brexit why are some countries
wanting to be part of you you this idea
that you come join a group and you are
better in than you are out you're better
as a group or you're combining your
strengths as nations that you work
together so you have common security
common rules and regulations common
understanding that idea which sounds
very noble a common market in a common
currency the euro but as a staunch
brexit here so I get called the female
Faraj quite a lot which is annoying
because he has really bad teeth so on
the 23rd of June 2016 we voted to leave
17 point four million of us voted to
really great people people tow inland
and the United Kingdom is made up of two
places one place is called London London
is Stan as I call it for obvious reasons
as you'll have seen coming from the
airport and the rest of it is called the
rest of the UK where I live where lovely
people live where regular Brits live
people that I really identify with and
for people in the rest of the UK a lot
of us voted leave and what's been very
traumatic is spending two years which
we're at now still waiting still not
getting to actually leave bricks it
hasn't happened and it looks
increasingly like it won't and that's a
very challenging thing for many of us
because it challenges are very belief in
democracy itself and our social contract
but the question is why did we want to
belong why do some people want to belong
you know some people the people that
live here in London that are doing very
well thank you or you know the elites
the establishment the people that are
very wealthy living in the biggest
houses in the centre of London old
London who are pro staying with you or
staying because their lives are great
there they're rich they have lives that
they don't want disturbed if something's
working why change it you get out into
the periphery the rest of the UK where
we are overwhelmed with migrants you
can't get an appointment for your dad at
the doctor's because there's too many
people on the waitlist you can't get
your children into the school down the
road because the waitlist is overwhelmed
and you start to really feel like you
want your country back and that was the
divide between London the rest of the UK
and the people that I know
so we're Katie so what is the benefit of
being part of EU so I mean I understand
you know it's 28 Nations - Britain let's
just say 27 or whatever way they put the
numbers what is the real benefit of
being part of you I think the real
benefit that people see is that they can
have the fluid movement of people they
say it's a massive benefit to be able to
move freely across the whole of the EU
that you don't need to have a visa you
can go and work there you can live there
and we can benefit from migration into
our country they say that there is a net
benefit to be gained from every migrant
that comes to this country there's a net
benefit we get from every migrant that
comes to this
that's what they say and of course I
would say the opposite of that and we
end up stuck in this central sort of
place where you say one thing I say the
other but neither side is listening nor
changing each other's views is it a
method where the EU will say hey Croatia
you got to take these hundred thousand
refugees and you have no choice yes and
if I'm cross I don't have a choice
business benefit you're part of EU we if
we were a country we are the third
largest most powerful military in the
world combined if we're part of you but
if you're part of you you have to do
whatever we tell you I'm Angela Merkel
although obviously I'm not because I'm
not ginger I'm not autistic and I
couldn't kill both my parents in the
night still turn up in a pantsuit in
Brussels at 7:00 a.m. which Merkel could
do without any challenge whatsoever
because she's crazy but if I'm Merkel
I've taken 2.5 million migrants from God
knows where half of who might be jihadis
I can now say to you and you are hungry
take these people and you have to say
yes although luckily Hungary and all
band have said no we won't love Hungary
I love Poland so that's the challenge
the challenge is to make a long you
don't belong so you get military you get
security you get the shared airspace
shared understanding of this you get ro
technological advantage sharing in
science you get migrants Bulmer but the
disadvantages you get told what you have
to do you have to pay your money you
have to pay and even though you might
not receive it and for example the
French can fish in our waters which my
Cornish fishermen friends optically you
can only touch what 20% of it right
what's the number that's out there on
your own water you can go in cash yeah
it just makes her mad just came out and
said we are still gonna fish in your
waters when you leave so we are still
gonna fish in your waters when Spain
just came out and said and we expect to
take some sovereignty back on Gibraltar
well let me ask you this what's the
worst thing that can happen if brexit
does actually become a reality what is
the worst thing that can happen in
Europe the worst thing that can happen
I see no but I see no bad thing that can
happen that only thing that could happen
to me is it encourages a whole bunch of
other people to leave which is precisely
why they don't want us to leave and I
think the great thing the media keep
using the narrative we crash out of the
EU we
crash no deal we don't crash anywhere no
airplanes are going to come falling from
the sky
we will politely leave in a very British
way apologize when someone else stands
on our foot and we just walk out the
door you know that's what No Deal means
we don't even have to pay to leave but
for some god only knows reason our
establishment won't let us leave
I truly think breaks it won't happen is
it the worry that's gonna be 27 against
one is that what don't worry is is it a
worry of war is the worry of you know
trade issues where people are not gonna
want to do business is it gonna affect
the money people de stablishment well
yes the wealthy in London status quo
works for them the situation as it as it
is now works for them why mess with what
you don't need to mess with for the
financial markets it's a prudent thing
to be part of the EU
why do stabilize that white why
challenge something that's working so in
America right now obviously we're going
through with China you've seen the
tariffs on what's taking place there and
some established CEOs are concerned
saying hey you know what we're being
affected by this because this is trade
like we wanted to business with them
they produce product for us cheaper they
do this they do that and Trump is saying
well yes at the same time these guys
have been taking advantage of us for so
many years that we're standing ground so
I can see what the business owner is
concerned about currently right now is
that similar to what the brexit
situation would be with EU yes the
anxiety what always change change in any
business model is create some level of
disturbance in the business it's hard to
make projections it's hard to make
long-term or cash flow even forecast for
cash flow is a difficult thing to do
when there's going to be change or a
dynamic in the business that you can't
plan for but I think sometimes in life
we learn you have to take short-term
pain in order to is what America is
trying to do with China I think take
some short-term pain in order to
establish yourself as someone that isn't
going to have these huge trade deficits
where China is clearly taking the mickey
out of America yeah I mean and you're
seeing that and I've seen in the numbers
so four so I do many too actually with
America I see that as well I agree so on
the EU side the smaller countries want
you to stick around because agrees has
been taken care of and hey you're taking
care of me I don't want the big guys to
leave because their money is funding uh
so it's EU helping bail
a lot of small countries as well
consistently or no I mean I'm such a
brexit a you aren't gonna get a positive
for me on the e no and well my question
will be the following it reminds me of
taxes which is the the ones that are
working hard making a lot California pen
57% in taxes and then you pain that
additional 13 and a half we're living in
California you paying some people that
are not paying taxes right so is it the
larger countries who are growing being
prosperous they're taking care of
countries like Greece and bailing them
out for their bad habits is that kind of
what's going on with you I mean Greece
say I mean to my knowledge and having
spent time there you know Greece was
utterly utterly more or less driven to
the point of collapse by the EU because
it has these punitive regimes for
repayment of debt and Italy's just going
through the same Italy is trying to move
its country forward and the EU is
penalizing them because it's saying no
you need to have a budget that helps to
pay back your debt
whereas Italy wants to expand it wants
to go into kind of a movement of growth
and the EU saying no you have to make
these contributions we need to keep your
country poor so I can't I can't honestly
for the life of me find a positive for
the EU but that's because my feeling of
hatred towards the way we've been
treated because we have not seen brexit
delivers is so strong and I would love
the whole thing to be broken up I would
love for the EU to be broken up for for
it to fall apart because I I cannot
abide to see Germany and France telling
other countries they have to give up
their sovereignty which is exactly what
they were talking about last week so
that's interesting you say that I guess
one of the questions I would have for
you would be the following I and I don't
have an answer for this I'm just curious
to know what you're gonna say about this
I went from Iran we wanted to get a
green card to come straight to America
we couldn't get it we escaped Iran six
weeks at the community that we went to
Germany and I lived at a refugee camp
for a year and a half and we had
refugees from all over and this is
Germany and then from there I come here
so I created jobs in America this is a
good story of a refugee that ended up
creating a good economy in America what
do you do to be able to practice I
understand the concern on the other side
as well if we just accept everybody so
what is the solution for it because is a
solution and you
a hundred percent to know or is it a
better filtering system and if it is how
do you filter them your story is I mean
it's why people would find it very hard
if I was a Democrat you'd be a very
spiky fish because I'd be like oh I want
to love him because he's a refugee and
he came from Iran and oh but then hold
on a minute he's made millions for
people and he employs vast numbers of
people and you've made yourself
extremely successful and made many
people very successful in democrats
would have to go run away run away he's
done too well for himself that's my
summary of Democrats for you but for me
yes I think what we need is an
immigration policy exactly like
Australia where we don't say ok we'll
accept free movement of people from
anywhere in Europe if you're French or
Croatian or German you can come here you
don't have to show anything you just
come on in we don't do that anymore
we open the UK up to the whole of the
world and we say if you're in India and
you are brilliant at what you do come
show us come show us earn the points a
point system of immigration just like
the Australians and if you've got the
skills we need your straight in if
you're going to work in our NHS and
you're a brilliant doctor you're
straight in it doesn't matter where you
come from you're welcome to our country
and that point based immigration system
is what Australia's run on and why
they've been so successful for years so
an immigration system based on points
points it's a point based immigration
system what value might bring into your
country yes you do you come in yes and
so I would score very very poorly right
now I'm of an age where I'm probably at
might over 30 or whatever that means you
score less points because you're going
to be a cost at some point in the near
future you know do I have am I going to
employ a lot of people probably not I
would school very poorly you on the
other hand would score magnificently
we'd be trying to drag you here saying
please come and that seems to me that's
the perfect system for our country that
sounds like Atlas Shrugged is what it
sounds like I don't know if you've read
Atlas Shrugged Ayn Rand so the whole
John Galt where let's create a community
of people of the best talent right is
that are you kind of Pro that are you
well just and not even the best habit
because I think so often people some
people have the best talent and we
should definitely grab them some people
just have their
incredible work ethic which is probably
where your parents fit in knowing a
little bit of who you are probably where
all those are first-generation
immigrants that came here originally
from India from Africa from he grafted
they were the hardest work and they
would outwork any British person that
kind of spirit is what we need not just
the best talent that someone who's
grafted so hard they want to work that's
the sort of people I want and am I
excited that 95% of our Somali
immigrants here in the UK are unemployed
no am i excited that 80% of our Somali
immigrants and females don't even speak
English no that's a real problem and
it's a problem you ought to be talking
about so so why would somebody pause
that idea why would somebody say no I
don't like the idea because i'm a racist
nfo bigoted misogynist white supremacist
Nazi and you can't possibly suggest
people need to be good at something to
come to your country because it's not
welcoming and it's intolerant
okay but somebody say that you know you
the whole multicultural thing wouldn't
that go against a multicultural thing
you're not saying that you're against
multi no I'm saying
India come Pakistan come come here
Singapore come if you hope great at
something get here but if you don't mind
if you're a jihadi right I'm not that
interested as it goes and if you're a
Somali who doesn't want to work and
who's eight wives aren't going to work
either
well not that bothered about having you
either if you're going to come across
illegally via the channel and pretend
you're Iranian as we've had 32 already
this month what no you're not going to
come either like some fairly basic
principles about what might be good for
my country and that's I think a little
bit the makeup of bricks or tears we are
actually these crazy racists we just
really quite like some people here that
want to work hard and do good things for
the country because we actually love
this country like I properly love my
country I will signed up to fight for my
country I couldn't do it my Pepsi and so
I fight in another way now I love this
place and if you aren't working and you
think I want to pay for your health care
no I don't same with my problem with fat
people if you weren't prepared to look
after yourself am I prepared to pay
you know I'm not it's very basic rules
for life back to my rules what has
changed from what you've seen the last
20 years with UK yeah oh this place I
don't even recognize the country I grew
up in anymore I don't recognize it I can
land at Heathrow people land at Heathrow
and they say to me I don't even know
what country I landed in you walk down
the street two blocks from here you
won't know you're in the UK that I mean
that is Lebanon up the road and then
there's no problem necessarily with that
other than it isn't multicultural we
don't have multi culture it's a word we
just got given and we have to pretend
it's real the UK is a nation of ghettos
I could take you now in a car to the
Somali quarter I can take you to the
Afghan quarter I can take you to the
error tray an area we are completely
divided and everyone brings those old
enmities old Rao's old fights with them
I saw this in the migrant camp at Calais
when I stayed there
you don't arrive looking for a new life
you arrive wanting to find what you had
at home and you bring your old fights
with you I don't recognize this country
I get emails from elderly people 87 year
olds and this might be the first time
they've gone on their grandchild email
to write this and they say that they're
glad that their time is nearly up
because they won't have to live to see
their country fall that that's the heart
of this country is elderly people who
don't want to live to see the end point
you know that's where we're actually at
how do you how do you prevent that like
you know how you said if we have a point
system and you have a point system to
attract the best talent from your doctor
your this your job creator your hard
worker come on down you score points or
something like Australia you come down
here let's just say I do score high I'm
still gonna bring my home town culture
etiquette rituals I'm still gonna bring
that so we're joined by something then
we're joined because we're joined by the
ethic of work we're joined by needing to
probably have a common language that we
share at work we're joined by the fact
that you want to bring your family and
you want them to belong as opposed to
keeping your wives sir plural inside the
house that's what we currently have here
I mean if you think about New York and
LA
in LA you have Chinatown you have a town
where it's all Armenians you have a town
words you know all Hispanics you have a
town have Skid Row no yes so we go to
skid row we want skid row for many many
Skid Row's a whole different story new
york same Italians Irish right they have
the same thing going on as well but if
I'm coming I'm coming to UK hey I want
to be a citizen of your country one day
but I'm a Muslim I'm a you know a person
that grew up behind my religious beliefs
aren't necessarily the judeo-christian
lamps that I have you don't mind that
but you don't have a problem at that
uncomfortable with don't be what you
wanna miss your country what you want
you can tell me you're a unicorn on
Fridays and a vegan on Tuesdays none of
those things matter they're just parts
of who you are as long as we're come
join by a fake respect for British
values and a notion that you're here to
do this country good how do you how do
you know if I'm on the same page with
your values because because work is a
key it works based on work is an ethos
to me that define so many of the values
that we intervene common that make us
who we are they make us get up in the
morning turn up be vaguely civil
probably have a shower at some point
during one of those days and try and
learn a language that you can converse
with at your place of work very
fundamental things that we've lost in
this country right now so what if what
if let me let me let me give you a
complete different perspective are you
comfortable with this what if we do the
point system and three hundred thousand
Muslims from Saudi Arabia from let you
say Dubai Iran Afghanistan Pakistan
hard-working people who believe in
entrepreneurship in capitalism they all
score high on the point system that you
have in place but they're all Muslim
you're comfortable if three hundred
thousand of them come here you have zero
problem with that I know zero problem
there is a problem with that in the
sense that I would need to be clear I
would want to be clear with if you're
now representing three hundred thousand
Muslims we'll go with that but I'm
scoring high on your point yes and I've
got that I love your points but I'm
going to let you know that Britain is a
Christian country with a Christian
culture and a Christian heritage I'm
going to let you know that you're free
to practice your religion but at no
point will your religion dominate my
country at no point will your right to a
mosque
override my right to have an art
Center that you've just taken over you
can't control it's a tough thing that's
what we're seeing what else how do you
can't control that because but what you
can say is as they are now doing now
with gate builders with the freedom
party is to start to row back on the
ability of the Muslim culture to
completely take over our own and that's
something we're fighting against all the
time don't you think I'm fighting that
don't you think
and idli like an angry woman in a paper
bag
why Miu and Nigel are on the same page
on a lot of it I had about two teeth yes
that you made it very clear at the
beginning yes isn't that part of the
ambitious like if I'm more ambitious
than you are and I want my religion to
grow more than yours
yes you can't go you can't prevent that
well I haven't been doing a good job but
I need to do a better one so I'm gonna
say to you yes okay you can have an eID
message from Sadiq Khan but we're gonna
have a Christmas message from the Prime
Minister have you seen Theresa Mays Eid
message literally this year she looked
like she was in a hostage video she was
literally thanking our British Muslims
so hard she looked like she was taken
hostage by al-qaeda her blink twice if
you need help to raise her bling
tomorrow mayor think about your mayor I
don't even want to think about my mayor
how do you feel about your mayor as
useful as tits on a nun yeah it's pretty
useful useless he's he's knife crime up
by 75 percent murders up by 82 percent
he is the most useless mayor we have
ever had but because his voter base are
Muslim and London is a densely packed
Muslim community he knows he can get
back into power he doesn't need to do
anything but placate the Muslim voters
who will vote for him hence we had an
eID party just over there down the road
at Trafalgar Square a party thrown for
his Muslim voter base because they'll
vote for him doesn't but doesn't that
doesn't that mean the point system may
not work well no it means that we need
to do a much better job of defending our
Christian culture and very clearly we've
let that fall in the UK I think the
Christian culture is more passive than
disagreement yeah then the Christian
culture had a meeting with group
masters in I think we were in Newport
Beach is where we were at right and we
got up and I started speaking to them
about what I think the Christian
churches are not doing right I think
there's a they don't support each other
and more as much as they used to it's
very much of no my congregation my
congregation my congregation in our
congregation we believe in sprinkle we
did we do this you know so many
different days and the Muslim community
sounds they're more United than the
Christian community and that's why they
got what a billion and a half people are
in the world I don't know the exact
number but I think from one point
through to one point five billion people
around the world I see more ambition
there it is then I see on the Christian
side so I don't think this is a issue of
religion more the leaders at the top are
not as ambitious as the other ones so
how can you if it goes at this pace and
it is nice probably donations on
Christian churches been flat for a long
time it's not going up the only
denomination that's grown not the only
do you know there's a few that are grown
lbs Mormonism's grown very very fast
their denomination the way they support
each other if you come out with a movie
I have to go watch it if you have a
business I don't see that with a
Christian but I see a lot of that with
the Muslim yeah of course so where their
their plan and you know I've just seen
someone put a GoFundMe up for another
mosque to be open in the in the upper
reaches of Scotland in some way out of
the way I learned I'm hugely a one
houstab well by the fact that they beat
the target by an extraordinary amount
which makes no sense and I'm
uncomfortable about it because they're
colonizing Scotland as well in my
personal view well because I always want
to ask Muslims it's my big question you
know if Islam is so fantastic why do
muslims always come to christian
countries for refuge why to convert i'm
going to places that are non camera I'm
not a Muslim myself no I'm not but you
know I'm processing it as a question to
give you my own theory I'm coming to
convert why go to a place when there's
all Muslim I want to come and convert
you yeah so then why do we let people in
to convert our Christian culture well at
what point did we become appeasers at
what point did we go from being Winston
Churchill bla bla bla our darkest hour
fight them on the beaches how do we go
from that to all of those
people out there right now that happy to
lie down let our country be taken over
give sovereignty to Spain tell France it
can fish in our waters what became of us
where are my strong men
where are my British men it's what
Americans asked me all the time what
happened to British men if I have to put
it on somebody isn't that the fault of
the churches being united on the same
page to be just as ambitious and
competitive to want to drive their
message out because people really just
enough but think about it think about
this you believe in free enterprise yes
your croak approach in business Pro
Castle ISM yeah my son is a competitive
come let's see who produces better
product if you believe in capitalism in
pro competition isn't there an element
of that in religions as well to choose
the most competitive to be able to
convert the most people because if
that's the case they're winning we
weren't aware of the fact that the
Muslims are winning here in the UK it's
the thing that's terrified me for the
last twenty years the only difference is
of course the Christian faith as well as
being more apathetic and not fighting
for our Christian culture that so many
of our forefathers did to talk decide to
defend is that our religious scriptures
our Bible doesn't actually go out and
tell us to kill non-believers you know
that's what those guys are reading and
that's why it's been very disturbing for
me to see our daughters blown up just up
the road here at Westminster Bridge to
see our daughters blown up just up the
road and stabbed at dinner on London
Bridge and to see all of our daughters
blown up at Manchester at a concert that
is linked to that religion whether they
distance themselves from it or not and
it terrifies me that my country has
fallen and my message to America is
always do not let yourselves fall as we
have fallen do not let yourself get to
the point where you're getting emails
from 87 year old saying I'm glad that I
will die before I see my country for and
I look at Minneapolis or Minnie Somalia
and I look at Minnesota and what you
guys just did in your midterms and it
you can't see it coming that you just
changed your rules on headwear just like
that
just like that Ilhan Omar walks in boom
change the head where you know that's
the start point you start to submit you
will capitulate all the way that's how I
feel I in
that's a good assessment you're making I
think Europe is a testing ground for us
right well then be scared yeah no that's
what I'm saying if somebody's watching
is the first you test your methods here
and then we're gonna come to the big
dogs big balls in US and say hey let's
see if we can go raise them that's right
and that's the message from South Africa
I spent three weeks with South African
farmers being hunted off their land now
you know they say they have two years
left before there will be no whites in
South Africa and the message from South
African farmers is do not lay down your
arms you know they will come through
your arms and of course the Second
Amendment is the thing that they come
straight after do not lay down your arms
well you know for me I'm a proud
Armenian proud Assyrian proud Iranian
and proud American it's it's it's like a
bipolar relationship I'm my parents are
Christians I was born and raised in Iran
there's a part of me that has affinity
connected to the Shah and what the
regime of Iran was at the time where
everyone around the world used to the
rich people used to go to Iran and party
and Frank Sinatra and you know all these
Taylor and and you know ambassadors now
Elizabeth Taylor and just it was like
one of those things I have a foreign
boyfriend you know there was a certain
thing to it and I'm not saying it's not
there today I'm dying to go back to Iran
myself to experience it I want to go
back and say I haven't been there since
89 but I see some of that so why don't
we transition to a different topic here
let's talk a little bit about your love
and passionate support for for people
who are overweight who have carrying
some a couple hundred pounds of baby fat
you know our stones as you guys call it
here instead what did that come out of
when did you start talking about yeah so
I'm not a fan of fat people tell me why
and then call them chubsters you just
been on a flight I'm sure your seat was
lovely but you know when someone else's
carries their leg on your leg on a
flight or someone's arm is on your arm
in a flight that uh-huh it's just makes
my whole of my skin crawl what do you
actually tell them when they're sitting
next did you say oh no I go yeah I'm
gone
I ask for different seats yeah I don't
travel with someone else's body parts on
me no no no I'll press the button and
call for help I will say sorry this
person how often do they help you out
India comedy oh they'll move me because
they can see I'll be a problem but I'll
say this person sorry next to me should
have booked to see
they didn't now they're taking up half
of mine I need to be moved I'm straight
up with that that's no problem for me
because when I check in we have these
budget economy airlines I don't know and
like when I check in my bag I have to
pay like thirty dollars right so look
you know I'm a hundred and thirty pounds
I'm paying for my bag which is probably
20 pounds and pay you not you but
someone who's very large like you who's
like 250 pounds you're not paying for
this that you're carrying on with you
but I've had to pay to check my bag
economically we would both agree that
model is flawed I am being penalized for
being skinny so my view is that when you
check in you weigh in
so you weigh in at check-in and you do a
cumulative total you plus your bag me
plus my bag and then you see if we need
to pay so if you're a fat person with
luggage you're gonna pay more and that
suits me fine and economically that
principle is correct because you're
internalizing the externality of the fat
person
second up I'm 130 pounds to prove
because people oh you're so lucky to be
skinny you're still lucky to be skinny
you're lucky to be scooty and I was like
no I'm not if I sit on my ass what do
you call this bottom yep bum you call it
one we call it ass ass if I sit on my
ass and I shove food in my face I too
can be fat and so I did so I put on half
my body weight I put on 60 pounds in
three months you did that yeah I was
huge and I took it off again in three
months to prove that fat people are lazy
so that I'm not lucky to be skinny but
if I do what you do and sit that oh I
can be fat too and I was really fat it
was called fat in back it was a
documentary it was you know so what do
you say what would you actually tell
people who you meet that they say well
you know it's a weird it's a it's either
genetic he's not my fault all the
excuses um that's why I did fatten back
to say I was on medication Christ for as
an epileptic you the meds you take up
the chart big bones don't run in the
family like if I x-ray you your bones
are the same size as mine that's just a
fallacy when you say oh I come from a
big family
yeah that's cuz all your family eat like
elephants and eat half the fridge on a
Friday because you're all fat together
it's not that it runs in the family just
all greedy like get over it so it was
just about if you walk a bit more and
eat a bit less you'll lose weight and
people did have you heard of Lululemon
the brand that really nice yes right the
really nice no but you know the problem
of that stuff hmm fat people put on that
stuff they feel more comfy they eat more
that's why if you're fat you should
always wear a tailored trouser because
it will hurt your stomach when you start
stuffing your face a tailored trousers
this is a definite stretch it doesn't
stretch and that's the dip thing I
learned when I was fat yes
all of a sudden you go into this weird
way which is not really a size it just
expands to fit you know what the founder
said he the chip Wilson I was with him a
few weeks ago with a beautiful them thin
yeah I mean shape you know person a new
lemon doesn't know I'm brandy and
telling ya here's what he said he
predicted he said in 20 years
everyone's gonna be in shape he says
because we're creating so much
predictive analytics that if you're not
everyone's gonna know why you're not in
shape yeah that's his well this is my
big thing because of course this in an
American sense
I sound jolly mean in a British sense if
you think that I'm paying my taxes into
a National Health Service I'm paying for
you if you're a fat person I'm paying
for your new hip your new knee I'm
paying for your gastric band to try and
stop you eating and I don't want to pay
for that I don't mind if you're fat and
you want to pay for it I don't want to
pay for it
and if we just had a social insurance
system where if you ran to work you've
got points if you ate a salad from this
place you've got points if you Sai court
or joined a gym you've got points and
that way you were incentive eyes to keep
you know use an economic model to drive
good behavior that's what we do our off
at our office everybody has one of these
we bubble
these four everybody would pay bonuses
every month if you have steps every
month so what I know I got to work and
I'm seeing my guys lunchtime they're
walking one hour I'm like wow when are
we pay bonuses you pay bonuses for every
single bone this is mind you would you
employ someone who was morbidly obese
would I employ someone so I longer hire
everybody at the supports but for me if
I'm looking at an executive I will tell
you if I see that you can't handle your
discipline when it comes on to your
health I wonder if you can handle
discipline other ears right because I'm
solving for stamina and energy how long
can you last I can't if you're gonna get
tired at 4 o'clock because you're you
dragged English no I so I tried this on
a breakfast there was a very large lady
I said well I wouldn't implore you
because you're too fat because you
wouldn't have the stamina to run my day
sure and because at the end of the day
there may be an odor issue mm-hmm and
because I said this directly to a lady's
face that was seen as being you know
hugely offensive where I think actually
a bit of honesty on the planet would be
a good thing we've come a long way from
being honest in order to protect
people's feelings and that's not so good
no we have a lot of that going on the
states as well so you you briefly talked
about taxes why don't we transition to
taxes a little bit sure so how do you
feel about the current tax system in the
UK in the UK it's for me
I think we should be massively reducing
our tax system the state is just getting
bigger and bigger and bigger therefore
of course the designs of the state and
the need to fund the state is getting
more punitive on people that work
because we've decided to open our
borders to everyone and who wants to
come here from Afghanistan and Somalia
the burden on a taxpayer like myself is
increasing we have an increasingly
elderly population and fewer people
working so unless we start to majorly
reward entrepreneurial talent and reward
those who run small businesses I fear
you know we're going to end up in a
situation where we're still going to
carry on taxing people to death without
ever rewarding anyone what is it right
now what is at Apple 40% 40% yeah so 40%
of your income will just go is it is
that
flat for everybody with annual making no
no so it's a sliding scale yeah it's a
progressive tax system but if you're a
small business owner for example you
know that to me is the the engine of
this country that's the part you can't
obviously give tax breaks to everybody I
understand that but I think we should be
giving tax breaks tax incentives to
small businesses because they're the
ones that struggle and I think some of
our employment models as well your
American system is far better so you
have higher at will fire at will we
don't have that try to me so if we take
on an employee basically we've reached a
system where the employee has all the
rights the employer has none so to take
on an employee is like almost like a
noose around your neck because they're
going to be very hard to move along or
get rid of without them taking you to a
tribunal literally literally you can't
do what the Americans like that
they always see it as I sort of always
protective for the employee whereas of
course if you can hire and fire it will
you're more likely to hire someone as
well which is always a thing and the
second thing that I think in terms of a
small business and as a small business
owner is maternity laws I really like
the laws in the states I had my first
pregnancy in New York and it was I think
twelve five weeks 12 weeks unpaid leave
I think is your maternity policy use you
say that's it no we've had many of them
I think it's around three months there
yeah like you your face is like that's
no more here you try saying that
somewhere in the EU you're stuffed so we
have twelve months like leave for
maternity time can you pay you pay for
well you're paying for a massive
proportion of that and now you have to
give paternity leave for the father who
doesn't work for you as well see but I
think that actually goes against women
it indirectly perhaps cools it down the
government if a business owner is
thinking about hiring somebody they're
gonna hire them a male who is not yes so
that the only the only way to have this
conversation is with an American who
goes yes I get that you try saying this
here in Europe and people like well
she's just she's a misogynist she hates
women
what but the truth is for a small
business a maternity can completely
crucify your
you're for 90 days is what you look good
okay you chose to have a baby I didn't
I'm your employer I didn't I mean great
that you're gonna have one but I don't
want to see the scam picture and B I
don't want to pay for it Thanks never
bring me a scam picture mm-hmm not
interested what's your sales tax this
year sales tax in the UK is 20 percent
sales tax is 20 percent 20 percent I
like that we're six to nine percent your
sales tax is 20 percent
our government is greedy but 20 percent
20 car for $20,000 I'm paying $4,000
sales tax in UK yes or if I'm needing a
service obviously 20 percent will be
added to that that's craziness total
craziness I know so you're now tax you
know you're taxed if you earn your
money's you work really hard you're
taxed at 40% so you're taking home 60%
of your money then you go to buy a car
and you're going to lose 20 percent of
your money again on the taxes for that
car so that's why this state and the
size of the state matters because
they're spending so much of our money
out about it the bigger the government
gets the more taxes they got to keep and
get more taxes you have to pay and what
do you get in return how strong is your
military how great are your roads how
great is your you know any kind of
public stuff that they make and if you
asked someone that you know the rest of
the UK the brick city is my kind of
people
how great are your roads how great your
military how great are your hospitals
and your schools your public services
how great your police force the people
in the UK will tell you we are this is
where we're falling this is where you
can see these services just disappearing
before our eyes our military is is all
but gone I mean our biggest thing is
whether we can accept more trans people
into the military people are obsessed by
that our police spend their time dressed
in you know rainbow colors dancing at
pride parades
you know this need to be politically
correct is overwhelming us to the point
where our services are so much
diminished we've become a shadow of what
we formerly were and they don't like to
talk like that about my country yeah I
mean obviously it's very obvious you
love your country yes even talk about a
downstairs and what you said earlier
when we started the interview in the
people and real people in this country
are amazing
they don't have this voice and that's
the hardest thing who is that
by the way who's the complete opposite
of what you're saying that's the biggest
proponent like who's whose views are
complete opposite of yours that's mine
of yours like total opposite like if we
have an Colt or we have rachel maddow
who's a complete opposite outcry the
other day false tears killed me so yes
if I'm Ann Coulter you would want or
some crazy lefty from The Guardian
newspaper that's who you need do you
have a name is there somebody that's
yeah I'd like to meet with oh there's a
range note so like a poly toy be she's a
lefty but she's not that interesting
she's got bad hair I'm trying to think
of some kind of fun Lefty maybe a little
get here little maybe a little chubby
trans person let's get a chubby trans
person of color no but but the part the
part I'm trying to like we're reaching
out to Bernie Sanders
I'm with Bernie he keeps saying no I
mean we want to sit with Bernie Sanders
cuz we like Gloria Allred have a lot of
respect for because at least she sat and
she faced Jerry Springer did a lot of
them did but the thing we never need to
you know as always my fingers well never
need to agree like so to be able to
engage in a conversation we never ever
need to agree that's a universal thought
I have so when people say to me I don't
agree with everything you say but I
think you're there so I think you're
great whatever I always want to say but
I never asked you to I never asked you
to agree with anything I said in fact
when did it become a precursor to debate
that we had to agree on anything
we never did and more people need to
kind of suck that up as a message I
don't need to agree to be able to chat
yeah yeah I'm a crazy lefty in the UK I
did you know the thing I'm the thing I'm
really struggling is cuz I just can't
figure any one kind of dynamic and fun
and interesting okay don't want to offer
up somebody hey you don't be dull all
the left are dull if you know anybody in
UK that meets the criteria we are
looking for send me a tweet so you can
tag both of us our handle is here my
handle is happening anybody anybody
think how do you case disabled claiming
benefits
an immigrant asylum-seeker he Somalia
who's disabled doesn't speak English and
is claiming benefits that is the
opposite me yeah well that's what you
get if you don't get me you get it short
interview with the dullard final
thoughts I'm gonna give it to you what
are your final thoughts final thoughts
on how you view things being in the
future in UK either a a part of a
paranoia or optimism
what do you final thoughts you I have
massive optimism because I have to fight
in me and that isn't going anywhere no
matter how much they try and crush me
with the police or they could take away
my jobs on my home I'm not going
anywhere
- we are growing so the rights is on the
rise gert builders salvini in italy the
AFD Merkle's just been removed from her
post we are building hungary Orban
poland all of these places are saying no
to the EU and the populace are rising up
3 we have Trump we look to Trump as some
kind of hope and inspiration strong
borders I love Trump I'm gonna marry
Trump one day many a better watch out
and so there's massive hope and America
and it's the reason I commit so much
time to America is because there's still
hope for America you have not fallen as
we have fallen you still have the right
to bear arms I'm a signed up member of
the NRA so you have what I need you to
defend and I know America can because
America will always believe in God and
the land and those two things will keep
you strong so tremendous optimism for me
I love it so that's amazing
I love seeing your optimism in your
country in the world and even other
places I like the fact that we had
conversations we talked about things we
agreed and disagree and I can't wait to
have you back on talking about other
topics when you're in the States or when
I'm out here and if you watch this and
you're still watching this and whether
you're upset Fury is saying I agree
disagree we want to hear from you send
us a message on Twitter tanker and tag
me and we will respond on what your
biggest takeaway was from today's
interview haven't said that Katie thank
you so much thank you so really enjoyed
it thank you yes
you